en 2010 huit nouveaux règlements pour
protéger les milieux humides est entré
en vigueur au québec
si collectivement on profitera tous de
la présence de ces milieux humides qui
devraient payer pour les protéger pour
l'instant certains agriculteurs dont les
terres abritent ces écosystèmes trouve
que la facture est salée
[Musique]
eric van welden cultive des légumes à
napierville en montérégie
[Musique]
c'est l'un des plus gros producteurs
maraîchers du québec une partie de son
succès c'est cette terre dont la valeur
agronomique infime ans ce n'est pas
magique pour les légumes qui a fait tilt
une pac est capable de donner de l'eau
qui gardent des lots vraiment facile
pour les légumes la région est surnommée
le triangle d'or du québec en raison de
l'abondance des terres-noires c'est la
mousse de tome c'est du bois or qui en
décomposition c'est un matin des
compositions center notre substrat c'est
avec ça qu'on cultive
c'est de toute beauté dans cette région
on trouve beaucoup de milieux humides
perturber ou détruits
[Musique]
c'est ce genre d'écosystèmes que le
gouvernement veut désormais protégés car
les milieux humides comme les marais où
les tourbières rendent importants
services à la population en absorbant
les surplus d'eau ils agissent comme des
éponges et préviennent les inondations
ou l'érosion des berges
la majorité des milieux humides du
québec sont des tourbières elles sont de
formidables outils dans la lutte aux
changements climatiques et séquestrent
33% du carbone de la planète
[Musique]
guy garand a été l'un des premiers à
parler de l'importance de préserver les
milieux humides à laval il a contribué à
sauver l'archipel du mi temps et
promoteurs immobiliers
le nombre d'années le plus tapé le nuage
je t'appelle tous venus à de rares
clichés de la nuisance au développement
[Applaudissements]
mais les luttes de l'écologiste n'ont
pas tout porter fruit dans sa région
40% des milieux humides sont disparus
entre 2004 et 2009 principalement au
profit de promoteurs immobiliers pour
résoudre ça rapporte pas un cas ce temps
ça rapporte pas une mare moteur a
parfois un oiseau ça t'apporte pas un
coeur rouge non plus une quenouille nos
bidons réveillez-vous le monde ça fait
partie de votre environnement et c'est
primordial de conserver ces
dénonciations alerter l'opinion publique
à tel point que le ministère de
l'environnement a fini par demander une
évaluation à l'échelle de la province
le mandat a été confié à une équipe de
chercheurs cours dirigé par stéphanie
pèlerins une biologiste spécialiste de
l'écologie des milieux humides
c'est facile de dire on a plein milieu
naturel au québec pourquoi les protéger
parce que c'est parce qu'on en a
beaucoup on doit se permettre de tout
détruire
à l'aide de photos aériennes et l'image
satellitaire les chercheurs ont dressé
le portrait de la disparition des
milieux humides de la province
entre 1990 et 2011 premier constat dans
les basses terres du saint laurent la
région du québec la plus propice à
l'agriculture 19% des milieux humides
ont été détruits j'ai l'impression que
ça se passe dans le corps on est
préoccupés mais ça fait moins de clopes
à 6 on ne laisse pas son envol
on les allume inhumé dans la vie les
superficies incroyable de milieux mail
au québec on a des supers c'est
incroyable de milieux naturels
quand les détruire on n'a pas
l'impression de l'urgence
les principaux responsables n'étaient
pas ceux que l'on croyait
seuls 5% des pertes étaient attribuables
au secteur résidentiel
[Musique]
c'est l'agriculture qui venaient en
première position avec la destruction de
44 % des superficies de milieux humides
le plus surprenant selon les chercheurs
c'est que la vaste majorité des
agriculteurs n'avaient pas demandé de
certificat d'autorisation
il y avait une grande côte au mit entre
ce qu'on pensait qu'ils étaient la
problématique des milieux humides et
seront ce qu'on voyait vraiment sur le
terrain c'est flagrant
on les voit disparaître par petites
superficies à la fois voici quelques
exemples de milieux humides qui sont
disparus au fil des ans avec ou sans
autorisation
à saint-etienne de beauharnois un milieu
humide s'est tranquillement effacé au
profit d'une terre agricole à oka un
petit coin de champs cultivés à enquêter
sur un boisé
à lanoraie cette tourbière a lentement
été grugés par une culture
et à saint-étienne de lauzon la
superficie de cette terre a presque
quadruplé en milieu humide c'est comme
ça à la grandeur du québec
c'est là les plus grands milieux humides
compères ont les parts de façon sûre
noir sans vraiment s'en rendre compte
c'est pernicieux mais
fo ne croit ses pertes la sont réels
les grands constat c'est que ces faits
dans l'illégalité donc les pertes on
voit des milieux humides en milieu
agricole sont pas du tout autorisé
québec en a pris bonne note et a conçu
une réforme qui vise zéro perte nette de
milieux humides
[Musique]
désormais quiconque détruit un milieu
humide doit payer une compensation
financière
pour déterminer quels secteurs doivent
être protégés le gouvernement du québec
a fait cartographier tout le sud de la
province
une compagnie spécialisée a pris des
images aériennes à l'aide de caméras
infrarouges
elle a identifié tous les étangs les
maires et les marécages et les
tourbières des régions le territoire y
est grand mais c'est pas parce qu'on en
ait beaucoup aujourd'hui que dans trente
ans on va en avoir beaucoup
on parle de certaines régions mrc qui
sont un espace de vingt et un ont perdu
30% de leurs milieux humides
si ça continue à cette même rythme dans
un bar dans 30 40 agents non plus
[Musique]
depuis quelques années eric van linden
et préoccupé
en montérégie les terres noires sont en
danger elle s'oxyde rapidement ce qui a
une incidence sur leur durée de vie les
scientifiques s'entendent pour dire que
si rien n'est fait elle pourrait
disparaître si 50 ans
[Musique]
pour faire face au problème
l'agriculteur gardait en réserve 112
hectares qu'il souhaitait éventuellement
défricher
mais depuis que cette superficie a été
classé tourbières boisé un milieu humide
à protéger l'agriculteur ne peut plus y
toucher
s'il veut cultiver ses nouvelles terres
il devra verser 5 millions de dollars au
gouvernement les milieux le 30
importants mais les légumes aussi là que
pour faire un choix qu il ya un juste
milieu à voir entre les deux je pense
qu'il faudra négocier un petit peu puis
voir comment comment on peut s'aligner
l'agriculteur aurait portant une
alternative
les maraîchers tout comme les
propriétaires de bleu est fière et de
cannebergières ont obtenu une exemption
de la part du gouvernement
s'ils désirent passer outre les
compensations financières
ils peuvent restaurer ou recréer milieux
humides à la place de celui qu'ils
auront détruit une pratique contestée
par certains
l'accumulation de la matière organique
qui a pris les milliers d'années à se
faire c'est pas en vingt ans on va la
recréer donc même sont créés même si on
restaure ça reste que c'est parce qu'on
avait à l'origine hills c'est une pâle
copie des milieux humides
l'association des producteurs maraîchers
du québec me mettais en obtenir d'autres
concessions en échange de la destruction
d'un milieu humide
les maraîchers voudrait pouvoir par
exemple garder des boisés autour des
chants élargir les bandes riveraines et
cultiver des couvre-sol ils servent un
avertissement au gouvernement ce qu'il
faut comprendre aussi c'est que fils et
légumes sont pas faites en montérégie où
ou dans les jardins du québec
ben les légumes olives et de la
californie puis là-bas ce moment là la
californie ou du mexique le cd des gaz à
effet de serre aussi important pour
l'environnement
ça joue aussi long
guy garand lui les met en garde
si on détruit dix minutes plus tard ils
vont se tirer dans le pied
peut-être un jour ici pompe dans terre
des eaux souterraines pour arroser le
chambon peut-être apercevoir qui vont
manquer d'eau
[Musique]
de toutes les régions qui ont été
cartographiées jusqu'à présent c'est au
saguenay-lac-saint-jean on trouve la
plus grande proportion de milieux
humides ici 17 % du territoire est
désormais protégée par la loi
on s'attendait pas suspendu ça fait que
c'est sûr que ça fait un effet boeuf et
choc
on n'a jamais dit qu'il faut pour les
protéger mais mon petit fils de quoi de
logique ensemble
[Musique]
j'espère actuellement c'est une forme
d'expropriation mais un centre sans
aucune compensation
patrick déry qui pratiquent
l'agriculture de subsistance à la baie
et le des producteurs touchés par la
réforme
il cultive ses légumes possède un petit
troupeau laitier et élève des moutons
pour sa propre consommation
[Musique]
il y a quatre ans il a acheté un boisé
de 26 hectares à quelques kilomètres de
chez lui il voulait le cultiver pour
faire du fourrage pour ces animaux mais
ces travaux de défrichage ont été
stoppés par une plainte disant qu'il
contrevenait à la nouvelle loi pour en
avoir le coeur net il a fait appel à une
biologiste spécialiste des milieux
humides la tourbière de chez patrick
déry je voudrais stéphanie lemieux et
son équipe ont analysé les cartes des
bassins versants de la région qu'on voit
ici en jaune et orange ils ont découvert
que la terre de patrick déry est
traversée par plusieurs cours d'eau puis
ils ont procédé à la caractérisation
écologique de la terre de l'agriculteur
présence de thé du labrador speg sol
organique sur plus de 30 cm de
profondeur
tout cela ne trompait pas
là on a affaire à une tourbière qui
était dans un bon état malgré que ça
déjà été cultivé mais c'était quand même
un milieu qui était assurée elle qui
était bien repris pts qui remplit ses
fonctions tourbières donc la
compensation est assez salée
7 millions huit cent mille dollars c'est
le montant que patrick déry devra payer
s'ils s'entêtent à cultiver cette terre
qui valait 40 mille dollars il ya à
peine quatre ans ce n'est complètement
leur entame pour rentabiliser avec 26
pts naples
j'espère cet argent que j'ai mis dans
cette terre là aussi donc pour nous
c'est une grande perte
puis on est un peu un peu pris avec tap
une bande qui a tombé comme ça et puis
les gens disent non mais qu'est-ce que
je serais moi avec ça maintenant
[Musique]
comment je fais pour vendre ce terrain
l'eau qui en théorie vaut plus rien mais
bon des millions en compensation et
contrairement aux maraîchers qui ont
obtenu une exemption les agriculteurs
comme patrick déry n'ont pas d'autre
solution pour soi aucun sou est un pays
on dit mais vous n'êtes plus chez vous
on ne fait plus rien faire chez vous
puis mais on verse avez vous continué
d'être propriétaire d'avoir la
responsabilité de cette terre
oui les chronos il m'appartient de paul
chagnollaud il fait par nous ou un capot
bien appeler çà comme voudrions un
poisson une tortue des bois hier bernard
aubril ça m'appartient pas mais sans
participer c'est important à la
collectivité
ce serait logique que la collectivité
participe à protéger son
[Musique]
si tu peux plus cultivé milieu humide
puis a pas moyen mais compensé nous pour
les valeurs clés qui sont en jeu puis on
va vivre tout cela que ceux ci une
expropriation ça serait expropriations d
au moins on sera pas dans un engin dans
une situation qui est complètement
aberrante l'actuel maire en attendant
certains craignent les effets
collatéraux de la nouvelle loi
est ce que cette loi lauvaux pour faire
en sorte que on va avoir tendance à
empiéter en secret dans les milieux
humides plutôt que si on arrive à
s'entendre avec des soit les rachats et
ray ou des compensations qu'ils sont
plus sont plus honnêtes
est ce que ça aurait pas plus de sens où
plus de réussite peut-être c'est
exactement ce qui semble se passer
présentement sur le terrain quelques
agriculteurs dont nous tairons
l'identité nous ont confirmé qu'il
tentait d'échapper à la surveillance du
ministère de l'environnement en faisant
des travaux dans des milieux humides
visés par la loi
nous reproduisons ici leurs propos les
agriculteurs ceux des pages et fonce en
cachette parce qu'une fois que j'ai fait
le gouvernement lui il peut plus rien
faire
je vais essayer de m me clôture avant
qu'ils mettent militaires dans les zones
humides
c'est au tce parce que si j'en parle
publiquement je peux avoir des amendes
est ce qu on le fait et on n'en parle
pas on a déjà commencé à défricher
[Musique]
nous en sommes maintenant rendus on va
que rapporter ce legault l'assomption la
loi sur les milieux humides et hydrique
a été adopté par le gouvernement
précédent
ce charrette de montagne pour 103
contrecoeur abstentions le vote avait
été unanime
[Applaudissements]
la province se relever de fortes
inondations qui avaient sensibilisé la
classe politique à l'importance des
milieux humides
[Musique]
mais en septembre dernier
benoit charette le ministre de
l'environnement a laissé entendre que la
loi serait bientôt assoupi
l'enregistrement sonore de cette
rencontre publique qui s'est tenue à
saguenay était jusqu'ici passée sous le
radar avec l'exercice on se rencontre
qui a sans doute été adoptée trop
rapidement aux stands au printemps
prochain qu'on arriverait avec avec une
proposition de modification à ce niveau
là pour corriger un certain nombre de
vérités très très important
[Musique]
à
impossible de savoir quelles
modifications il entend apporter à la
loi
notre demande d'entrevue a été refusé
parce que pas un critère en commande
attendre pour voir qu'est ce qui va se
passer dans les prochains mois parce que
un peu tout le monde dans cette approche
là on va attendre voir qu'est ce qui
modifie on est déçu
on peut plus se permettre aujourd'hui
d'altérer des milieux mine parce qu'on
voit atteinte à la biodiversité pour
risque de mettre l'humain en bas âge et
par des inondations et des grandes
périodes d'étiage qui va amener des
grandes sécheresses dans le territoire
donc je faut être très très prudent
pour une fois qu'on faisait un pas
important pour la protection de
l'environnement au québec recul et se
serait montré que pour tous les projets
qu'on va vouloir mettre de l'avant on va
toujours être capable de reculer
donc est ce qu'on va faire confiance en
nos institutions pour protéger notre
environnement
[Musique]